-Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy-
and Grammy-winning comedian
who stars in the new show
"The Afterparty,"
which premieres Friday
on Apple TV+.
Here is Tiffany Haddish!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, making an entrance!
Come on!
Oh, my -- [ Laughs ]
Making an entrance.
Come on.
Only you.
I love you, bud.
Welcome back to the show.
-Mwah, I love you, too, Jimmy.
-You know, Tiffany, I was very
excited to have you on the show.
You've been booked for months.
We want to talk about
"The Afterparty."
And I know you had a very public
breakup, and then I just saw
you were on the news last week.
And so I go, "Hey, you know..."
and hopefully you know this,
"...that I'm your friend."
So I love you.
So you're always welcome
on the show.
But you can always cancel on us,
as well, if you want to.
[ Laughter ]
But you were like,
"No, I'm a pro.
I'm gonna come on."
So I appreciate you coming on.
I mean, can you --
-Well, I appreciate you
having me, Jimmy.
Thank you for, you know,
allowing me to be here.
-Can you talk
about anything that happened
or want to talk about it or no?
-Well, I can say this, Jimmy.
-Okay.
-I've been praying to God to
send me a new man, a good man.
[ Laughter ]
And God went ahead and sent me
four in a uniform.
[ Laughter ]
I wasn't expecting it.
Was not expecting that at all.
[ Laughter ]
And now,
I got a really great lawyer,
and we're gonna work it out.
-Yeah.
-And I got to get my --
my asking of things
to God a little better.
-Yeah, got to be
a little clearer.
[ Laughter ]
That's very good.
I'm very glad
you're here tonight.
I understand it was a tough,
tough week for you.
I mean, you lost a few people
very close to you.
I'm very sorry about that.
-Yeah, yeah.
I mean, one of our mutual
friends, Bob Saget,
who was, like, a big mentor
to me, a big brother,
father figure, he --
he meant a lot to me.
-Funny, funny, funny dude.
-Funny man.
He was the first white man to
ever tell me, "Just be yourself.
Just be who you are, Tiffany."
[ Laughter ]
"Don't worry about nothing.
Just be you."
-Is that right?
-And that was huge for me.
And then,
my grandma passed away,
and that --
She saved my life.
You know, that was --
That's my heart.
Like -- she was,
like, my soul mate.
-Yeah.
-That's been really hard
to process all this,
you know, grief.
-Yeah.
-The grief.
-Well, if you were here,
I would --
I would give you a hug,
and I would say,
"It only gets better."
You know?
And these are the tough times,
and you're gonna get
through it, and I love
that you came on our show.
This is the first step.
I love that you did this.
I'm, like --
It takes a lot of guts.
So I appreciate that.
You're awesome, buddy.
-Thank you. Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We're comedians.
We got to make each other laugh.
We got to make people happy.
-Right, right.
Well, also, you know,
just being in your presence,
even though it's through Zoom,
it's, like, through the energy,
it's -- it brings me joy.
-Good!
-I miss you.
-I miss you, too.
-And this is
how I get to see you.
-Take this --
Take this, maybe,
and, hopefully, make something
out of it, you know?
-Oh, I'm definitely
making something out of it.
My next special
is gonna be about grief.
-It is?
-And it's gonna be hilarious.
-I love that!
I love that you're doing this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
Because figuring out
how to process it,
you know, process it all --
kids get to cry
whenever they want to,
wherever they want to.
As an adult, you can't do that.
[ Laughter ]
You can't just
cry at work like that.
They send you home.
[ Laughter ]
-That's right.
They send you home.
-I mean, I need my money.
-They do.
Well, do it.
Make a special
and win another Grammy,
will you?
Congrats on --
-Oh, I sure will.
-Congratulations on winning
that Grammy, by the way, bud.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-That's -- a Grammy
is a really cool award.
Out of all the awards,
that one's, like, cool.
Because you kind of grew up --
-It is. It is.
You can drink out of it.
-Yeah, exactly right.
[ Laughter ]
Exactly right.
Yeah, I -- but you,
as a comedian -- I don't know --
you don't even dream about
winning a Grammy.
You think of, like,
Michael Jackson or somebody
or, you know, Whitney Houston
or somebody
winning all these Grammys.
You don't think that a comedian
is gonna win one,
and then you have one.
-Never. Never.
I remember the first time
I was nominated for a Grammy
for my audiobook,
for reading out loud.
I was like, "What? What?"
Like, "You can get a Grammy
for reading out loud?"
[ Laughter ]
And I called my drama teacher
immediately,
my high school drama teacher,
who taught me how to read.
And I was like,
"Girl, you did a good job!
Just got nominated for a Grammy
for reading out loud."
-"I'm a Grammy-nominated
reader."
"I'm a Grammy-nominated reader."
-Yeah.
-I read something funny in one
of your interviews recently.
You said that you want to make
80 films by the time you're 50.
-Yes. But I don't want
to be in all of them, okay?
I just want to make them.
I want to be
a part of
the moviemaking process
in some way.
80 of them by the time I'm 50.
-Why 80?
-Because it's a nice,
well-rounded number.
And it seems to me that,
you know, if you make 80 films
that, you know, you're --
you're an official entertainer.
You are, like, the thing.
[ Laughter ]
-80 fil--
I love that.
I love that you're doing that.
Because I saw --
"The Afterparty," by the way,
super funny.
Oh, my gosh.
I mean, what a talented cast.
You sent a couple pictures.
This is you
as a camera operator
on "The Afterparty."
-Yeah, yeah. See?
[ Laughter ]
I'm a camera operator already.
-Does this count?
Does this count as one of the --
-Yes, that counts.
To me, that counts.
You know, I put in an invoice
for a check
for the camera operator job.
They didn't pay me for that
part, but I put in an invoice.
-How about --
How about boom operator?
-Boom operator.
[ Laughter ]
That's why I got
these strong arms.
You know, bam!
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
-I want to talk about
"Afterparty," if you can.
Because --
Let's just, how about this?
What was your best after party
you've ever been to
in your life?
-Best after party I ever been to
in my life would have to be
the Jay Z/Beyoncé gold party
after the Oscars.
-Oh!
-That's the best party
I ever been to, because, first
of all, good music, good food.
And then, there's something
about when you're, like,
dancing, you know,
eating all some fries
and dancing and you look over,
and there goes Rihanna.
"Hey, hey, Lupita!
What's up, girl?
Oh, Leonardo!
What's going on, Leonardo?
We ready!
Hey!"
Oh, Beyoncé dancing with me.
Me and Beyoncé dancing.
We getting it, we getting it.
Now, most people
would be intimidated
to dance next to Beyoncé,
but I feel like Beyoncé
is intimidated dancing next to
me, because I got them moves.
Okay? I been killing it
on the dance floor.
Mostly my pinky toe.
-That's crazy.
-'Cause she got me
some slippers.
She was like,
"Here you go, girl.
You ain't got no shoes on.
Here you go."
-That's right.
That's fun.
I want to hear more about
the show and see a clip from it
when we come back.
More with Tiffany Haddish
after the break, everybody.
Come on back.